good morning believe nation today's
message is create what you like
over to you seth rogen we make the
movies we want to go see I mean we found
that when you go in meetings there's a
lot of you know with studios and various
producers and stuff there's a lot of
talk about who will like the movies you
know you make this movie these people
will like you make this movie and these
people like it and they're all kind of
guesses stabs in the dark almost and
then that's what we realize you know the
only people that we know that we can
make movies for is ourselves so when we
sit down at a movie like pineapple
Express we thought what movie do we want
to go see what's the trailer that we
watch and we say that's the movie that
I'm gonna throw down my money for that's
the movie I can't wait to go watch and
yeah that's that's really all it is it's
you know you could guess all day as to
what other people would like but you
know what you like so that's what we try
to do is just stuff that we would want
to go see thank you guys so much for
watching the question of the day today
is I'm curious what is the last thing
that you created that you really really
really really liked yourself you created
for yourself what was the last thing you
made leave it in the comments below I'm
gonna join in the discussion I also want
to give a quick shout out to Knoll
Brosnan Knoll thank you so much you're
picking a cup of my book your one word
it really really really means a lot to
me thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of espresso
hey believe nation if you want to stay
inspired on creating the things that you
like
stay tuned for some special bonus clips
and I don't think in terms of like
retrospectively retro actively looking
at what I did and how I got to where I
am instead it's much more of a focus on
what do I want to do that easy because I
think that if you try to consider a
cater to your audience
too much you will invariably end up
making something that's much yeah
because I don't know that the audience
knows what they want to see I know that
I don't know what's gonna pique my
interest if I knew how to describe the
perfect movie blog television show I
would just do it I want to see something
that surprises me and what I think of my
own work that's exactly right like I put
my head down and I try to ignore the
world and I try to make something that I
think is really good and if people like
it great if they don't I don't care as
long as I like it so I think like if I
had one thing to attribute all this
growth to it's that I'm making work that
I feel embodies the same level of
integrity of anything else that would
invest myself into do you have a
specific target audience or just anybody
who can read anybody who's literate it
used to be again when the comics were
just for little kids or they were
thought to be for little kids Thanks
yeah yeah with Marvel because we started
directing marvel at ourselves really the
foot the theory was we're gonna write
the kind of stories we would enjoy
reading you say and I didn't know if it
would work or not but it worked better
than anybody expected because we grabbed
a lot of readers who are much older who
like the kind of things that we liked
but we didn't lose the young kids so we
ended up we have kids seven years old
who read Marvel who don't understand the
subtle implications and ramifications
and the psychology and philosophy of the
subliminal moralizing but they love the
nutty characters and the long underwear
the colorful costumes and the older
readers enjoy all the little subplots
and the littlest sides we put in and the
little things that a young kid can't
ever grasp but they're there in the
story it's a happy medium yeah so we
find the best formula if you call it
that is we don't try to write for any
audience we try to write stories we
would enjoy and apparently there are
enough people in the world who have the
same tastes I hate to say that I'd like
to think my tastes were smart better but
apparently everybody must have pretty
much the same taste was the book sell
pretty well when it comes to pleasing
people listen of course you want to have
a good reception but you don't make a
movie by committee and so I have to make
a movie that I would want to see and I
have to create a character that I am
interested in and that's it I put my
head down and I focus on that and I
don't really pay attention to what
people may be requesting because I
believe that if we have enough
conviction and what we're doing that
people will believe it as well do you
think the secret to your success is
actually that you are in many ways in
the way you lead your life your tastes
are quite average middle-of-the-road the
kind of stuff that the mass market would
like sure absolutely right and I don't
think you can make records utter that
you can make TV shows properly unless
you can sit there as a listener or
viewer you can't guess what people like
it would be like me guessing what you
want for dinner it's impossible I can
tell you what I want
so I base everything on my own tastes
and I have you know fairly broad you
know I'd say quite simple tastes I think
I think originality period could crack
not only the UK anywhere originality is
people people's people straight away
from that every time people do music or
anything they do now they do it like
someone who has done it before or they
do it like what the people want I don't
do that I do it I do what I know it is
nice to me I do what I think is cool and
if you don't think is cool then I think
you're not cool so if you approach me
with that attitude announcing
Kevin Lucy Street